so this topic will be maybe a little bit
of a change of pace a couple of days ago
at the end of the show I mentioned a
horrific encounter that I had in an
elevator and and it was a horrific
encounter because someone spoke to me
someone made small talk and that's a
horrifying thing there's nothing worse
than small talk in an elevator and
because it's this enclosed quiet
environment where you cannot escape
sometimes you can't escape for up to you
know 20 to 30 seconds and that is 20 or
30 seconds of torture now I said that
when I am dictator of America I will
impose a new regulation forbidding any
conversation of any kind in an elevator
upon penalty of death and also requiring
that elevators elevator music must be
played in elevators so as to alleviate
the awkwardness of the sounds now some
people emailed me after after that
discussion and they were very confused
and they said they said you know what's
the matter with small talk Matt are you
shy are you anti-social do you do you
hate people why do you hate small talk
so much it's pretty rude it seems like a
pretty rude thing for you to not want to
make conversation with a person it's
pretty it's pretty rude that you don't
want to talk to somebody on an elevator
so on and so forth now what you find in
these responses is something that people
in my community that that my people okay
that would be introverts deal with
everyday we are we are painfully
misunderstood and that's even though I
assume half the country it's probably
comprised of introverts or at least a
very large percentage even so we happen
to live we live in a culture in a
society that is designed for and by
extroverts and so they get to define
everything and they get to define us and
their definitions and their perceptions
of us are wrong so what I want to do for
a little bit of a respite from the
heavier topics is talk about
this strange sort of person called an
introvert and and and and how they
operate you know what it means to be
introverted and why we hate small talk
because I think this could be useful
half of you watching this will think
well this is a stupid useless topic but
the other half will think yes thank you
finally someone is explaining
the first thing is this
on a personal level yes personally I am
I am an introvert through and through
yet I give my opinions publicly for a
living I travel around the country I
give speeches in front of crowds and I
don't dread
I don't dread public speaking you know
in fact I really enjoy public speaking
it's it's my it's it is my favorite
thing that I do professionally without
question in spite of the fact that I
would certainly qualify as an introvert
now this is only surprising to people
who don't understand introversion and
confuse it with shyness I'm not shy at
all I have no shyness to speak of which
is why I can get up in front of 500
people and talk to them and not only
have no problem with it
but enjoy it so there's no shyness yet
there is introversion
in fact if we're standing and for if we
were standing in a crowd of 500 people
and you said Matt I need you to go and
mingle and make a small make small talk
with like five or six of those people
that's why I need you to do if you told
me to do that I would dread it I would
refuse I wouldn't want to do it but if
you told me Matt I need you to get up in
front of all of these people on a stage
and talk to them for an hour I would say
great I'd be super excited to do it it
reminds me of something that it reminds
me of something that Jerry Seinfeld once
said when he was while he was on stage
doing stand-up he said I can talk to all
of you but I can't talk to any of you
and that's kind of what it's like to be
a non shy introvert although there are
shy introverts and there are they're
just like there are shy extroverts as a
matter of fact being an introvert and if
you think about the term introverted it
kind of makes sense being an introvert
means that you draw energy from quiet
from solitude from being alone with your
thoughts and your imagination you like
silence you like to think interacting
with people drains you that doesn't mean
that you hate interacting with people or
that you never want to or that you want
to be a hermit out in the woods although
there's a certain part of me that would
find that appealing but it doesn't mean
that everyone want that all introverts
would like to be Hermits it just means
that you have a very limited supply of
interacting energy okay there's a
there's you there's you have a finite
supply of that kind of energy for the
day and so you prefer to use it wisely
you'd rather use it on for instance one
three-hour in-depth conversation with a
friend or maybe giving a speech in front
of a crowd or something like that
you'd rather use it that way then on 95
different small talk exchanges with
strangers on elevators and elsewhere now
on the other hand an extrovert
draws energy from interacting with
people an extrovert feels most at home
talking to people he feels most
energized mingling and chatting and
interacting and so on
my wife is this way my wife is uh is the
prototype of an extrovert
she loves talking to people she makes
friends everywhere she goes she'll go to
the grocery store and she'll come back
and tell me oh you know I met I met a
woman there she has twins too this is
the same ages are we're going on a
playdate on Tuesday and I'm like what
you made a friend running
Aaron you made a friend at the grocery
store you were gone for 32 minutes and
you made a friend in that time how why
how could this possibly happen it's it
to me it's totally foreign I would never
happen to me ever but um but it happens
her all the time
so I'm married to an extrovert I respect
dr. verts I I feel that I understand
them but I don't think that the
extroverted approach is the only
acceptable one even though if even
though our society is kind of set up
demanding that of all of us I don't
think it really is the only acceptable
approach and the idea that it's rude or
bad or wrong to not be completely
sociable all the time is just ridiculous
the idea that you're required to talk
all the time to everybody everywhere you
are I find that that to be a ridiculous
idea
there are insurance or just different
sorts of people
and and to us to me speaking as an
introvert now you might think it's weird
that well why wouldn't you want to talk
to people it's a weird thing to me it's
weird
I hear people that say you know that
to them that the worst thing in the
world would be to go to a restaurant and
eat by themselves at a table like they
think that's the weirdest most
uncomfortable thing to me it's weird
that you think that's weird I do it all
I'm out traveling all the time I'll go
to restaurants I don't care I'll go to a
restaurant ghetto you know it's not even
like I'll go to the bar oh I'll get a
table and sit by myself if I'm traveling
at a right had a sit-down restaurant and
eat it doesn't bother me at all in fact
I like it it gives me time to just eat
and drink and think but there are people
who can't stand the idea that they fight
they would find that horrific to just be
by themselves eating somewhere so not
everyone's the same way everyone has
different personalities and different
approaches now let's head back to the
elevator the question is
I don't I why don't introverts in
general if I may speak for all
introverts
why don't we enjoy small talk on
elevators and elsewhere in life and I'm
gonna try to explain that now but
explain why small talk is the bane of an
introverts existence there are there are
three reasons okay number one most
importantly and this this is really the
main thing
it feels insincere
and as introverts we absolutely loathe
insincere conversation we hate it we we
we we absolutely hate it we're very bad
at it we have no interest in it we don't
like to talk to someone who we know
isn't really interested in the
discussion
and if this if the discussion is about
the weather or about traffic or some
other banal thing then we know that you
the other person in the conversation
that you are about is interested in what
we are saying as we are in what your
what you are saying which is neither of
us are really interested so to us this
feels like a wasted interaction our
finite amount of people energy is being
depleted by this completely useless
exchange that is of no interest to
anyone concerned now here's the thing
despite popular belief it's not that we
hate talking about we enjoy conversation
we enjoy meaningful conversation so we
want to get to know in a conversation
for us like we want to get to know the
other person we want to hear their
thoughts and their perspectives we want
to get an insight into who they are
we're very interested in that but if
they are not invested in the discussion
and they don't care what we are saying
and we don't really care what they're
saying because it's just it's it's a
it's a you know pointless
then we kind of shut down and we say
well there's just no point in this
conversation the same thing could happen
even in an even in a non small talk
discussion if we if we think we're
having a meaningful discussion but that
we look like we're talking to you and we
think it's a meaningful conversation and
then we start sharing our point of view
and then we look at you and we see that
just dead eye expression that kind of I
don't care at all about what you're
saying expression or we get that expert
or we start to get the the feeling it's
one of those we start to get the feeling
that that really this is one of those
conversations where you're just waiting
for your turn to talk that it doesn't
really matter to you what we're saying
the moment we start to sense that
we just shut down we don't want to have
the conversation anymore because it's
not that we're offended or feelings are
but it's just twice it's pointless okay
well you know no no hurt feelings
nothing personal but let's stop at let's
stop talking now there's no point of us
talking
now you might say
well you need small talk in order to
transition into the deeper subjects I
hear that all the time well this is this
is a necessary transitional thing to get
into deeper you need the small talk
portion of it but no see that's not how
we work that that's how you work as an
extrovert maybe but we don't
we would have no problem whatsoever just
jumping right into the deeper topic we
would jump right into politics or
religion or whatever without the
transition the transition from our
perspective the small talk part of it
that impedes conversation and gets in
the way of and puts off and interferes
with the more meaningful interaction
and if we're in an environment where no
meaningful conversation could possibly
occur because there's just no time for
it or it's not the place for it like an
elevator then we just as soon stay
silent because there's nothing can
really come of the discussion anyway
second thing
we are up in our heads all the time
constantly
and we like that you know we like to be
there thinking and imagining and
wondering whatever it's not a
self-absorbed thing it's not like we're
always thinking about ourselves we could
be thinking about anything we could be
talking about the news or about a family
member or about God or about walruses I
mean really who knows we could be think
about anything but if you rip us out of
that
then we prefer it if you have a good
reason
the moment start talking to us you have
ripped us out of our out of our thought
process and I don't think it's
unreasonable that we would prefer if
you're gonna do that that you have a
reason for doing it and so if you have
to relay important information to us
that's a reason if you want to have a
real meaningful conversation that's a
reason but if the reason is just to make
an observation about the weather if the
reason is just to say oh it's raining
outside
then maybe we were a little put off by
that
we know you didn't mean anything by it
we know you're trying to be friendly but
but we see friendliness in different
terms so for us it could be friendly to
not say anything to a person and just
let them continue along with that with
whatever thought process they're
following at the moment for you
you're being friendly by talking about
the weather but from for us we could
we're being friendly by not talking
about it or not talking to you at all
and not bothering you to us that's
friendly third thing
I've already explained that we're up in
our heads all the time and that means
that we're very analytical about things
so we analyze everything we especially
analyze human interactions
so we will leave every small talk
conversation analyzing and assessing our
own performance in the exchange
while the extrovert may leave the
exchange and just go about his day and
not think about it anymore for us we're
left thinking about it inspecting
ourselves giving ourselves a grade on
the whole thing usually it'll be a
pretty poor grade although sometimes
we'll walk away saying oh you know wow
well done maybe that was pretty yeah
those a b-plus small talk performance
well done and then we have to go take a
nap because we're so drained and
exhausted by it but we prefer to avoid
this we prefer to avoid what - what what
- us is kind of a high-pressure
situation that will lead to a very tough
self-analysis so while silence may be
painful to you as an extrovert it's not
to us the pain starts when you break
that silence
and that's the difference between us
and personally I don't think that one is
wrong and the others right it's just
it's just these are just personality
types that's all now of course this
doesn't mean that we can avoid small
talk all the time it's a necessary evil
especially in our society I think we all
understand that it's a necessary evil on
the job it's a necessary evil if you're
like on the dating scene and in many
other situations
but it's work for us it takes effort and
it's exhausting and we don't like
doesn't come naturally
so kind of if you're an extrovert
imagine how you would feel as an
extrovert if you were forced to sit
alone and eat by yourself at a
restaurant or if you had to if you had
to sit in a quiet room alone for an hour
and talk to nobody nobody around and
nothing to do you just have to sit there
or imagine how you would feel if you
even if you had to if you had to read a
book by yourself all afternoon or
something like that imagine the the
discomfort and the exhaustion and the
wanting desperately to get out and to
get into your natural environment that's
how you would feel and that's how we
feel very small talk it's I don't think
it's rude I don't think it's it's not
shy it's nothing like that it's just
this is this is just our personality
okay hopefully hopefully that will help
you to understand a little bit the you
know 50% of the the people that you
share a society with alright well now
I'm exhausted
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed